[Music]
good morning depending on where you are
um so
yeah before we get started with the
talks tonight
uh i wanted to give a quick uh
presentation of pi data
and especially this pilot apparatus
meetup
so pi data in general it's a community
for developers and users of open source
editors so
if you are interested in more events
like this one uh
follow us on twitter you can find us at
with the pi data paris handle
um so pi data is actually a trademark
and an educational program of non-focus
so none focus
i don't know if you know it already but
it's non-profit
promoting accessible and property and
reproducible scientific and technical
computing
it actually serves as some kind of
umbrella organization for open source
projects such as numpy
jupiter pandas psychic learn and many
other projects of the community
and it really simplifies actually
raising money
and getting grants for developing these
open source projects
and pi data is one of the main programs
that they have
uh so first we have pad attack
conferences
so the conferences are multi-track
multi-days conferences and open source
scientific computing
we we have such conferences in berlin
new york city
budapest eindhoven in the netherlands
los angeles austin warsaw and many
others
some of them have thousands of attendees
one of the biggest ones is actually pi
data london
in europe uh since 2020 we've been
holding
pi data global which is which was for
the first time
an online event and fully online event
and so that went really well
um beyond the conference uh
we actually have pi data meter groups so
in 66 countries there are 186 groups
which
together account for over 180 000
members so that's really a really large
community
uh so in paris the paris chapter of the
pi data meetup
so today is the 15th event since may
2017. we have
over 3000 members we got 24 talks since
the beginning
and we are always looking for venues
speakers and sponsors for catering
or flying invited speakers to purse
um so we have a a code of conduct uh so
we strive to make pi data an inclusive
and welcoming community for everyone
so if you want to read the the complete
code of conduct you can go to the
nonfocus.org website
i provided the link in the presentation
but the short version is
please be nice to others do not insult
anyone or put anyone down
behave professionally remember that
harassment and sexist
racist or extra generic jokes are not
appropriate for them focus
so i've included like more content but
like the short version is like please be
nice to each other
uh if anything happens that to you or
someone else that you
witness and makes you uncomfortable you
you please do not hesitate to contact
the local meetup organizers so myself
emmanuel jacobits or sebastian freel
or if you are even uncomfortable with
telling the local organizers about
something that happens you can directly
contact num focus the
foundation with an online form or by
email so i provided the
the form link in the presentation and
the email address
if anything happens so
i just wanted since this this is the
very first time that we're holding this
pilot
appears meet up since the pandemics i
wanted to
tell you a bit more about the future of
pi data first so why are we doing
like this we why have it have been
organizing this meetup for like
over three years now one of the main
goals was to
gather the paris you know open source
data science community
and get them to meet and have a place to
exchange ideas and
unfortunately we didn't have any event
in 2020
because of the sanitary situation
but hopefully we'll get back to normal
by the end of the year with in-person
events every two
three months so we are already looking
for sponsors
and people who may want to host the
meetup in paris
so uh tonight we got quite an
interesting
um number of speakers
and we've uh we're going to start with a
keynote by roman reishak so roman is a
data scientist and for
founder of he has a background in
physics and he's also an active open
source contributor
in particular he's a core developer of
the psychic learn and piodide project
so now i'm gonna leave the stage to
roman
uh thank you silva so uh let me share my
screen
hi uh does this work can you see my
screen
yes okay great uh so
thank you thank you sir for organizing
this event and
today we're i'll start by talk on on
piodide
which which aims to to bring scientific
computing
uh with python to to the browser with
webassembly
so what we'll talk about today is we'll
start with this overview of the project
a bit
to discuss the features it has the the
limitations we have
or the like uh what you can do with
peridotite
we'll talk about about more concrete
applications and finally we'll we'll
talk about challenges and the different
roadmap
so during this talk if you have any
questions please uh
i i think there will be a time where you
will be able to comment on
the uh okay okay thank you
so so let's start with a bit of an
introduction of
webassembly so what's with assembly uh
it's essentially a binary
instruction format for uh for a virtual
machine
and initially it was it was designed for
browsers as a way to accelerate some
some kind of computation in the browser
where traditionally you would use
javascript but for some application
javascript
is not fast enough so people like uh
there was a design to develop
webassembly to respond to that use case
uh however now you can also use
webassembly
uh in other standalone environments so
for instance you can use it with node.js
which runs on the server
or you can use it uh with with the yz
you can
essentially just run arbitrary programs
with web assignment
so why it's interesting is because it's
portable
so portable means that you have the same
binary that's going to run on any kind
of
operating system and or any kind of
architecture so for instance
nowadays you can maybe you know you have
maybe more processors that run iran
in for essentially python it means they
have to recompile packages to
took for that architecture was web
assembly you just have one binary that
runs
like everywhere so it's it like it
promises near native performance
of course you have some some performance
overhead but essentially
the idea is to the performance is close
enough
and it's sandbox it means that you you
don't directly talk to the
to the operating system you have some
kind of sandbox in between
so for instance in the browser it's
going to be the the the same sandboxes
for javascript which is very
like thoroughly tested um so so
that that allows some some amount of
security of the code you run on your
on your machine so what we have now is
there there are projects that allow you
to take some c code or c plus plus code
and compile them forward assembly so for
instance you have
m script in project which which allows
you to do that so it would produce
essentially a wasp binary file and
you add some javascript code around it
and you can run that
inside the browser so it means that
essentially that works for
for like uh any kind of sql and
because well python is written in c like
c python
uh so that that's what was done in in
uh python is essentially we take c
python as it is so
really the source code of python we
compile it uh with m scriptin
we do the same thing for uh for
different scientific package
python packages that have a cx engine so
for instance if you want to compile
numpy
it's not just python code it also has
some c code
and you need to compile it um
and so all of that is is converted to
webassembly and so now you have
essentially an interpreter you can run
and you have
some of the packages we see extensions
that are available as well
and in addition uh so what we have is
there is a
like a implementation of a very small
part of what pip does
so it allows you to install packages
from ip so you can
you can this only works for pre-python
packages but it allows you to just load
the
like package that's in pipe i you can
load it in five diet and
use it and finally there is the python
javascript
type translation or foreign function
interface so what it allows you to do is
to
take a say a python function and use it
in javascript or the other way around
so of course you have the the project
repository uh below
and uh and now
um i'll maybe do a short parenthesis on
on the project history
so so the project started uh at mozilla
was started by mozilla michael
and initially it was a it was a language
plugin for iodide iodide is a is a
experimental notebook environment for
collaborative and
scientific computing communication so
unfortunately uh
the iodide project is no longer
maintained and
since then the support for mozilla has
decreased a bit
so uh as of this year we have become
like pie diet has become
an independent project so it has a
essentially it's it's a
community driven project with the with
the independent governance we have a
roadmap and a code expander
so of course there have been other
projects that built uh
you know python in the browser so the
one of them is for instance pi pi so pi
pi uh
took a uh like was before pi died
and the approach they took was very
similar except that they they used the
uh ismgs at the time which was the
precursor of webassembly
and so this project is no longer
maintained but it's totally it's
completely possible to do this for
princess for five uh so there's other
approaches such as
briton so britain is really a
re-implementation of the python
interpreter in javascript
and of part of this underline
um same you have the rust python which
allows which is your implementation of
python in rust and because rust builds
nicely to webassembly you kind of get
that mostly for free
and other projects such as micro python
boards which uh builds microfighters so
so the
the the general idea is that it's
possible it's
like like there are many ways to run
python browser that's that's fairly
there are many projects in that the
difference of fire dyed is that
beyond python what we would like to do
is to actually be able to use the python
ecosystem in the browser
and and the ecosystem is not just the
interpreter you have all those packages
including packages that have like c code
or fortran code or some other
compiled extensions that you actually
need to
to to compile to to to be able to use
um so let's talk about uh
cx10 the packages with c extensions a
bit so uh essentially the the core
all the core scientific packages enter
in this category so you have
well the first the the core package is
number uh then once you have numpy you
can compile for instance scipy but
sci-fi
is uh depends it has a depends on blast
so it's a numerical
computation library for matrix algebra
uh and what blessed
so and and the challenge there is that
you need some
some part of that is within fortran and
you know it's
uh getting a modern compiler like at
least couple years ago was very
difficult now there's a lot of project
with a lot of
progress in this area uh but so
generally that's that's uh the
so that's the idea so the core packages
are compiled and i haven't put the full
list here we have over 75 packages which
are
naturally included um and then you can
add additionally
uh parts uh you can load packages from
uh from pipe i would microwave
so so micro pip works only if you have
uh pure python wheels that are uploading
ip
so um in case you you wonder the
difference is that the wheel is
is just a zip file with uh
the source python source files already
directly included
so you don't need to run setup.pi to
install a wheel you just unzip it and
you can use it
and this may this means that we can
actually use it directly in uh
if you don't have a like if you have a
pure python package it doesn't have a
wheel
we can't use it buy that currently
because it it requires to run set up
with pie and
essentially a restaurant peep and that's
uh that's not
that's not currently um
so now so that's uh that's the like the
ideal case
uh well unfortunately in some like so
there's still some
modules that are not supported by by web
web assembly vms which is like if you
need
some processing or multi-processing or
if you try to use sockets it's not going
to work
so in this case we have to re uh we have
to patch
essentially the the project so it's just
to avoid the imports
some things like this and so in this
case you can actually
include the package as part of the
iodide build system which is
uh like vaguely inspired by condaforge
and we're trying to migrate in the
direction of better compatibility on the
forge so
we have uh what we have now is
essentially have a method.yaml file
you can just write your your system
there
and then so these files are distributed
by just deliver cdn
so you can uh essentially load them from
relatively
easily and efficiently when you when you
when you need them
so that's the general idea and we can
also mention the
the type translation api between python
and javascript
this is really the part that makes it uh
actually
interesting to use by died in a web page
because on one side
well you can use javascript from python
so for instance you have
in this example for instance you have um
you have access to the dom so you have
access to all the elements of the web
page
so for instance you can you can import
js which is a specific module pyrite
and there you can you can set the for
instance the document
[Music]
document title and it's going to change
the title so and you do that from the
python side
um so of course some people uh
saying well i don't like js i only want
to use python
and uh can i do that
so the answer is yes no because in the
end if you want to use python you have
a paradigm you have to have some
knowledge like some
you're going to get some notions of
javascript as well so um
for instance you can also use spider the
other way around so
from javascript from javascript you can
use some
global python object
yeah so for instance in this example we
we explored the python global objects we
take the sys module from there
and we created a javascript uh module
that's
uh like object that that rocks this
money
so maybe to be more concrete let's let's
do a short
demo uh to to illustrate a bit how we
can
use all this and uh what what we can do
with it
uh so let me try this okay
so uh so what you have here is the
is a rapple so it's a pilot wrap right
so it's it's a standard python terminal
so you can do like uh you know
basic uh basic python you can write
python code in there
right so now we can also import modules
as as expected right so we can uh for
instance we can export
standard library modules so here the the
interesting part is that
you know python is essentially a bunch
of files
somewhere in the file system and the
question is what do we have here so
for instance if you look at where this
this module is located it's located in
the underscore
slash sleep slash python and the thing
is i'm
for instance i'm currently using windows
because zoom otherwise doesn't work
very well and so essentially this file
system
is completely virtual so it's a in
browser virtual file system that's
provided by m scripting
and that's going to be essentially reset
each time you roll the page currently
so um so of course it's it's a file
system
so you can use usual python operations
on it so
for instance let's let's look at files
in there i don't know
okay live coding is is not definitely
that easy
but uh
so essentially you can you can do your
usual thing
like usual the usual stuff you would do
with python in this
in this webassembly vm where you also
have
like something that that looks like a
file system
uh so now uh interestingly we can
similarly load external packages so
by default you're not going to load any
of the like external packages
if we import for instance numpy
so what's going to happen is that behind
the scenes
uh pyrite is going to fetch the the
pilot package from uh
compiled for web assembly uh numpy
package compiled from
assembly and so we can do like the usual
uh
you know the usual operations for
instance
uh so similarly you can also um
load uh do you see my screen well
because it's
uh it's at the bottom of the screen is
it uh
yeah it's just perfect okay uh
so similarly you could for instance try
to load packages from piping
so to do this we we will uh import uh
microclip give just a second let me try
to hide this
uh so we will import them macro package
and we'll what we'll do we'll install
for instance uh
like an arbitrary package so say uh to
do this we'll do
so what we did here we installed the
package which is called snowball's timer
from pipei
and we use the avoid sentence so so
essentially you can use asenpeio
inside by that as of this last release
and it's in this case it's going to use
the emmett loop that's run by the
browser so it's going to reduce
essentially a
javascript event look to run async code
with uh with iphone and now that loaded
it
we can import it
you know and run some some operations
with it
so more interestingly we can also define
uh
uh for instance let's define some
function like this simple function
python
that does some kind of operations uh for
instance takes the square
so this is a python function now uh what
we can do is let's open a javascript
console
so you have a javascript console here by
the way it shows uh
um it shows what you have loaded uh
tell me if you don't see it if you don't
see the console um
and so uh and so interestingly we can we
can now access this function which is
item function from javascript so what
we'll do we'll do
[Music]
let's define it and then we'll do we'll
do
that
and so this function is actually a proxy
so it's a wrapper around our python
function
however we can access methods of it so
uh for instance we can we can access all
the
like the usual python methods for
instance name and we can also call
so for instance if you call tree you
name so what happens here is that
uh you you have you have this
proxy object that you pass a javascript
argument to it
the argument gets converted inside to to
to a nine so to an integer type inside
python
the function gets computed and then you
get the return back to javascript so you
have this bidirectional
conversion that's happening all the time
and so of course in the other way around
you can uh you can similarly do
uh you can define some uh some some some
variable in javascript uh
um and then you can you can access this
from
from python import
x and so here you have x and and the
type of x
is so you have you pass from a
javascript
string to a python string
so that that's that's a bit of an
overview and uh
the thing the the fact that you have
those conversions that work
this allows you to essentially do a lot
of interesting um
applications uh using python so let's
get back to the presentation
uh a question one can uh ask is
what about performance so how like uh
how fast it is
is it so what we currently have is
biodiet uh
like python with iodide is going to be
uh between
near native performance two three to
five times slower
it's there have been a lot of
improvement in last version so this is
the last release or
17. but but we're still uh
like noticeably slower than
uh done before than a native item so
there are some
um possibilities that are being explored
and it's possible to reduce this
this overhead further
so um today uh in later talks you will
you feel much more about applications of
iodide in terms of
notebook environments and um and
end user applications i'll i'll just uh
briefly uh mention some so
we have the pilot wrap which is which i
just showed you
um which is essentially a very simple js
console but it's sufficient to actually
illustrate most of the functionality uh
we have the iodide
project which is what how the iodide
started so it's it's an
interactive notebook environment that's
that you can access here but it's no
longer exported um
and then we have the the notebooks
environment so for instance we have the
bastown which is uh will be
i think um will be mentioned just after
my talk
uh so it's uh for like a fork of
chipturn notebook
um starboard starboard notebook and
jupiter sorry this is a type of uh
jupiter life
again i'll skip them because we'll hear
more about this uh just uh afterwards
but the general idea is that uh if you
take a classical architecture
uh between a front-end and back-end so
what you usually have is the user
that talks to some web page and this web
page is going to send requests to some
server
that's removed and the the server
probably has some
[Music]
item code or like let's say a kernel or
generally some computational code that's
going to run
that's going to maybe query database or
and
return the response in the case uh if
if you put actually your your code into
the browser
well it this allows you to run the
calculations directly there so it means
that
for instance if you have a python
algorithm that computes something on the
based on user input you can directly
compute it on the on the
on the front end and just maybe query
make some
queries when you need the data
so the the the advantage presentations
of this approaches are as follows
so in terms of usability that's that's
uh
doesn't really change much in the sense
that you you will get
uh be able to use python code
in the to run some computations without
installation it right
whether like you just go to a web page
um a very big advantage is scalability
so you can because
essentially you're just serving static
files and now you have
like cdn solutions that allow you to do
this at scale
relatively relatively easily so in terms
of
coast there is very little cost if you
have even you have a hundred thousands
of users
uh it's it's going to be transparent for
you the computation is not you don't
have to deal with where i'm going to run
the computation so
it's in some use cases uh particularly
for instance
education as we'll we'll hear later it's
it's
it's a it's a big advantage
um well you have also the potential the
privacy aspect because
since you run the calculations locally
you don't necessarily need to
send the query somewhere to some urban
server uh you might still need to
fetch some data from the more server and
there's also the
the question of algorithmic transparency
so because well it's python so it's just
uh
in the end it's just python scripts
right so it's files you can uh
you can inspect so you can if you have
an application that
that runs runs your python in
somewhere you can inspect it and you can
see what's what's happening especially
that it's in the
front end so you have access to that of
course that can be an
advantage if you're like if you're
interested in this aspect but it will
also be limitations if you're
you have some trade secrets you want to
protect and of course
uh we know that uh like in the case of
python that's that's
problematic you cannot really have this
schedule
so if you do a small uh small um
parenthesis on uh on uh on the case of
machine learning models how we deploy
them
so for instance if you take the
classical workflow is uh
you know we take some machine learning
model we train it we
serialize it on disk and uh here here on
the right we have like
some of the most frequently used
serialization formats
and then we're going to develop some web
service around it to serve this uh
this like to make predictions we package
it maybe in a container to
and then we deploy it on the server and
of course if you use
if you can could take your model
directly and just
uh you know directly run it inside the
browser
uh assuming it's not too big assuming
that
it doesn't require to download like
hundreds of megabytes of data
uh that can simplify a lot of this
deployment process
so and there are already tools that
allow you to do that so for instance
you have um onyx that does um
that's a standard circulation format
that works really well
you have and then you have like for
instance tensorflow has a specific uh
uh project that allows you to run some
javascript etc
but but the fact is most of those they
have
essentially a predefined set of
operators that so for instance you have
a model
uh that does some i don't know matrix
multiplications and the
matrix multiplication is supported in
those in this
projects and so you'll be able to use
them i mean i'm generalizing it's a
they do much more than this but that's
the idea but however if you have some
custom algorithm written for python
you're not going to be able to run it
there because well it's it's pure python
maybe use some additional libraries et
cetera
so and pi died what what essentially uh
what can um how it can intervene is that
for instance for the to do some custom
pre-processing maybe it's just easier to
like qualify that and do it there than
to try to
like convert it to like to the supported
operations by this
tools and also uh
like a nice thing about uh python and
serialization of item objects is that we
have the pickle format
so pickle is uh well it has a downside
so the downside is it's unsafe it's
brittle to environment changes
but the advantage is portable and
generally not
like non-opaque in sense that you can
load it and
get the original data so you have a
python class you just pickle it
you unpickle it you get your original
hyperplasty you can expect what
you can inspect what's happening there
um and so
this for instance can be used in in the
context of iodine so
what you could say uh you could do is
well you can create
an environment with the same versions of
python and dependencies as in pyrite
but you need that because otherwise
people will not be portable
in the case of machine learning model
you just record and then you can unpack
with inside iodide and you'll get your
model as is
and then you can for instance because of
this uh foreign function interface you
can
for instance call it from javascript
directly so you have
you have a small uh walkthrough here i'm
not
i'm not going to go into into it because
we don't have that much time left um
but of course so so this is still a bit
experimental there's still
uh let's say there's still some a bit
more work necessary to make
a particular project depend on sci-fi uh
completely fail file proof
um so uh let's
next talk a bit about the challenges
they're still there and the
the roma so the first
the first point is the download size so
this is the the main
like uh the people say okay we
we don't want to download the full
python right like uh so
currently a c python for the standard
library it's it's like 20 megabytes
um in pioneer we get uh we can
get it compressed so it's compressed by
the cdn to something like six
but it's still something like it's still
measurable volume
right and that that power only happens
the first time you load it so the second
time
you load the page it's going to be
cached by the browser usually
and uh so and this is you for instance
the fact that well
you have the large standard library
right so so you have standalone library
has a lot of things that you maybe not
don't necessarily care about
for instance in the context of iodide so
for instance if you have the digital
package
which is like 200 kilobytes so if you're
on your laptop 200 kilobytes it doesn't
matter
if you are loading it from the browser
the 100 kilobytes
that you're not using is kind of belongs
and so so that there have been like some
thoughts about maybe we should make some
of those uh
models uh like don't load them by
default but
for them optionally etc so similarly in
the central
computing space you have this you have
some packages that are really large for
instance sci-fi has
is is essentially an accumulation of
very different sub-modules
and you probably don't need all these
modules you probably need a specific one
so
maybe again there is maybe a question of
maybe we can load it uh sub modules
independent
so so i mean there essentially the idea
is that there's a lot of
um things that were done in the python
ecosystem
that they didn't really uh took too much
care about the size that you'll get at
them because it
doesn't matter in other applications
however in the case of pilot we now have
all those
those like questions and wondering what
we can do about it
to you know to for instance essentially
make it
faster to load the the problem is not so
much size but also how how fast you can
load the
uh the application so for instance if
you look at the reptil it's it's going
to take like around
maybe five seconds with good internet
connection and that's
that's significant um
other normal limitations uh well there
are those
of the web assembly uh virtual machines
so
first thing you have also processes so
anything that uses multi-processing or
or super processing is not going to work
uh currently there is no threading
uh so that's potentially could be
enabled but
browsers need to support it and browsers
enable support very recently so
we have to wait like some number of
months or years to
make sure everybody uses their recent
browser however you can
use um web workers
so which which is a kind of a form of
running something in parallel in the
browser so to some extent that could
replace
uh creating parallel processors
uh another very strong limitations you
have no they have no sockets
support so essentially you cannot for
instance make http requests
using all of the standard library
modules in python
and that's that's really unfortunate
because well a lot of python packages
assume you can like use a requests or
use
use standard library models
um well we'll talk about this point a
bit a bit later
uh well another thing is it's a 30-bit
two-bit architecture which is uh
i mean it's it's it's manageable but
it's also adds constraints
you know it's actually computing they
have like the support for 32-bit
architectures is not as good as
for 64-bit and generally the the thing
is
there are some system calls that are
essentially not implemented for instance
in m script and so you can very well do
i don't know you have some file and you
apply some
non-standard operation on it and like uh
you
you change permissions right that's
going to fail because it's just not
not implemented and then there are some
constraints uh in javascript big so for
instance you have no integer type
uh only like number type or big integer
type
there's generally well there are some
libraries that implement nd arrays but
there is maybe not
one that's really standard one
and um interestingly there are some uh
like keywords that that are reserved in
python but not in javascript so for
instance if you have an object that's a
javascript promise you pass it to python
and then what you would do is you would
want to do is you would want to call dan
on it except that then is a reserved
keyword in python so this is going to be
a syntax error
even though well that's the method that
you like to call so it's
i mean it's it's some anecdotal
uh points but it's it's it shows that
there are some
some things when you start to actually
try to apply it
on actual projects there you're like how
do i do this
and more generally so uh if you talk
about the roadmap what we have now is
uh what we would like to get is a
well smaller uh packages and faster to
load so
a very simple example is uh for instance
all the scientific packages
input tests by default inside the
package and i mean it's useful but you
probably don't want to load that
if you load not like pandas pandas like
probably half of the size is just us
and we can probably need to extract that
at some point during build time or
something
so the performance aspect
there is a question of could we maybe
re-implement some of the
standard library modules for instance
http client
to use web apis so you could actually
use
http client
[Music]
but underneath is going to call like
javascript
javascript functions and this some of
this is actually for instance done in i
think investment for
requests um there is the big challenge
of
scipy and for transport so currently we
can we can
compile fortran by converting to c first
but it doesn't work
well for all versions of fortran so i
mean there are like challenges there and
because safei uses fortran that's uh
that's something that
we have to deal with and more generally
there's the
question of how do we keep this
this package build system sustainable so
i mean it started as a very simple uh
implementation from scratch of the build
system because we had very specific
needs
of course there is like great
communities that exist already such as
condo forge so the question is
can we like shift some of this there but
at the same time
while keeping some of the constraints we
have that are really non-standard and
they're very specific to
this environment and like things like
trading that would
could happen uh eventually and of course
if you have a
like if you'd like to contribute
something or like a bit technical or
non-technical we're very
variable to new contributors uh so i'd
like to thank
generally the team uh first the team at
mozilla who started this project and
started like iodine iodide and
vertically michael
jordan the maintainers of
biodiet and very active contributors
well you have a full list on the right
and some
some of their like partners and related
projects who
so for instance excited who's who funded
some of my development uh like a few
years ago
um well bust on project uh
like starboard for like contributed to
patches back
and just deliver for for allowing us to
distribute
all those packages uh efficiently over
this again
uh thank you and uh do you have
any questions i haven't i haven't
checked chats so far so i guess they're
there yeah
there were some discussions in the chat
so
uh let me pick some of the questions uh
there was
one that you answered eventually so i
think i'm just going to skip that
there wasn't a question by rv about
um what happens when
you change a variable like a python
variable
after or like a javascript variable like
in this
uh you know sort of reflection mechanism
that you have and whether you see the
changes
in the other language yeah i'm sorry if
i just doesn't do the question right so
so that that's that's a very good
question so
uh yeah so so and there's there's a
one aspect that i completely skipped
here is how do you do memory management
because in python you have this
you know you have a garbage collection
in javascript you don't and so
so typically effect effectively when you
take a variable you copy it to
for instance from python to javascript
you're going to
access via the reference so if the
variable initial variable changes you
will
also see the changed object but but this
also means that maybe
the initial initial object got
deallocated somehow and then you're
still trying to access it or the other
way around you know so there's really a
lot of challenging questions of memory
management that enter there and that
aren't really solved yet and so that's
something really
like helpful okay
um so unless rv asks another question
or like a follow-up one i will move on
to uh there were a couple of questions
by olivier griezel
the first one was about native uh
threading whether it's possible to use
openmp and i think you partially
responded to that by seeing no native
threading
but then the final question was like
when browsers start supporting it
would we be able to do this yeah yeah so
so i mean
now bro like the latest chrome or
firefox they they do support
the problem is not everybody has the
latest from firefox so
that's why we haven't really added yet
but yeah essentially you will be able to
you you are you can't use
multi-threading be it
from python or openmp uh
like in c code because because
essentially what happens is
uh unscripted uh implements the system
calls i think the the
system calls so you can uh like you can
use it uh no matter
where and and so is
would it just work without any change in
biodiet basically
yeah basically enabling this i think
mostly i think
there are people who managed to compile
it so it was trading and i think it
mostly works
so i mean even now we essentially built
c python with very very little changes
so we just take the source code we build
it and it works it mostly works i mean
you still have a few patches but
it's very minor okay there was another
question value
sorry like there the thing scrolled
automatically
could we use the onnx uh runtime
to run arbitrary python functions in an
nx node
using biodiet so basically using a
highlight from
outside of the web browser i guess right
so so i mean uh to be honest i'm not uh
i don't know enough about honoring some
time to comment on that
uh so i don't i i don't actually know
everything you can do with onyx runtime
but you can i mean there are people who
managed
to build iodide outside of the
outside of the browser so for instance
as part of the
wasmer io or project and so essentially
what they have is they have this
their standard library for wasp so
you you build your project as you would
like normally
except that you use the special compiler
and the special standard library that
that's going to
like pass manage all the system calls so
uh so it's possible that's not something
we have explored too much but
it is possible right and like it will
give you a
host if he wants to ask the question
directly so let's make it a bit more
interactive
yes
hello um can you hear me yeah okay
yes uh just yeah so my question was
actually uh
would it be technically possible i
assume that the onyx runtime right now
do not do it do not support it but will
it technically possible for the onyx
runtime that uh run on the western
uh webassembly target to actually call
into piodide
to run arbitrary python function in a
node
i assume that it should be possible but
uh there is a lot of work to do but
yeah i i mean it's it's really a
question
can the next runtime on on your laptop
call into some python code if it can
then it will be able to do that in rust
as well i guess
the spec doesn't allow it but
technically if yeah
if you make it possible maybe they could
evolve the spec using an extension okay
[Music]
i have a related question is uh would it
be
possible to uh compile a llvm
using amp scripting into a western
machine and then
use a number in a biodiverse program
yeah so
that's it's a fairly frequent user
request
i mean i guess i guess it could be
possible but i haven't haven't
personally tried it
and i mean it's it kind of means you
have to
you know you have to compile vm visible
vm i don't really know what's
uh but yeah i i don't really know how
it's going to work but
probably okay thank you very much
i have a question yes so uh
how does it work for the reflection do
you actually patch
c python c code or is it like no
so you mean the the conversion between
languages
that's right yeah yeah so um
so essentially what happens is m
scripting uh
has capability to export c
functions into javascript so so that
m scripting by default allows you to
call like some c code from javascript
directly without
actually doing anything and so that's
what we use we because
like while python is just uh like the
core python is implemented in c
so we expose those c functions that that
uh
make it possible to call them from
javascript and therefore
that's that's essentially how it's
implemented
okay uh there is another question uh
that i actually initially missed and i
just uh noticed i missed it
from pico i think kiko is the uh author
of brighton
or like a maintainer of brighton maybe
i'm not okay
i hope i haven't said anything uh
anything bad about brighton
um so could the work done
by other projects like brighton um
uroboros translating some of the
standard leaps to js
be useful like
um yeah so
no yeah definitely definitely i think
those uh
especially for for um for everything
that needs to like
communicate with the web or something uh
um yeah that certainly that's something
that we could explore because i haven't
to be honest i haven't really looked in
detail
or or like those aspects but i think
that's definitely something
we should explore
okay thanks uh let's see are there any
other
questions in the chat anyone's wants
does anyone want a
last chance to
okay roman do you want to add anything
uh no thank you thank you for inviting
me and uh
well i'm looking forward to hearing next
talks
all right thank you um okay let me share
my screen again
and um
if you bear with me one more sec before
i share my twitter feed
because i was tweeting about this on
twitter
there you go um so
um we have the next presentation
is co-presented by uh roman cassatti
and uh nikola poonam so the
ramakazetti is a computer science phd
from uga
and he's uh currently a
high school math teacher and
so teaching computer science and math in
liesen
in france and nicolas is also a french
mathematics teacher
and trainer and is the co-maintainer of
the capital project
so now i roma and nicola i'll
let you the stage
we're not hearing anything here uh is uh
maybe you need to unmute
sorry sorry when i share the screen i
caught the mute so
i disable the sharing then i re-enable
it
so can you hand me and can you see yeah
we can hear you well now
okay i put a link in the chat
where you can load my presentation
from bathroom so
i put it in full screen is it working
okay so
so thank you thank you children for
the invitation first of all um
i would like to apologize for the fact
that
most of the resources here will be
french
this is because we are targeting the
french education so
so i would like to be sorry about that
but um
we plan to to to translate it
to to english soon so so it will be
in english soon um
i will present a project called fast
which is mainly uh
how to do peaceful everywhere and we
will also present
with nikola represents capital which is
how to work with baseball and students
and teachers
so you have a link to both projects
here
so how boring would it be um first of
all i will start with
uh why i created then we will have a
tour of bathroom
we will quickly see how it works we will
talk about limitations but i i think
this is mainly the limitations
that are presented by holland um
and then this will this will take about
15 minutes and for the last five minutes
uh nikola will present the capital
which is say investment for students and
teachers
uh so why i created that two years ago
um there is a reform in french
education for high school students that
say
that in science like math
biology physics etc
you you have to use python 3
but we are on our own as high school
teachers because we have to deal with
heterozygous installation
with students that doesn't know how to
install
a python interpreter or python
distribution
so we are on our own um there is no real
easy to use gdpr compliance and open
source solution to
to teach python so this is why i start
learning how to to develop but by easy
to use we actually require only an
internet connection and a web browser
by gdpr compliance we want to be fully
on site
this means this is a static website we
don't want to send cloud to to the
server
so i i i test a lot of solutions
and each of the solutions have its
own strengths and weaknesses
that's uh to our goal paradigm
seems to be the most advanced uh
solution
so here's the two of us i can't do a
live demo but
uh when i do last demo i forgot some
stuff so
so this is the video i i think it
it will be okay to to to comment this
this
video um so in better you have two
fontes
two front end the console and the
notebook
so here we will start with the console
at left you have
uh so here is the iodine here you have a
script at left here we have a
square function that we defined we can
then
execute the script
and use the function in the in the shape
that's right so you have nice uh
it's basically like the european uh
paradise because we just with the script
part
so you you you can have string
representation
like that but the basic demo of the
script
part of the front end so coming back to
the main page
you can see that we have a gallery of
examples
so here is an example in the in the
console
with matplotlib and and p that are used
so you execute the script and you can
see that
there is the loading of the both modules
and then you can see the graphics output
that that
prints the results that display the
results and then you can change the
function that's
plot start another figure
and you can you can modify this
and then there is no module reloading of
course
it's it's real time
so coming back to our main page there is
also a specific modules that are not
biodiverse this is uh
purely teaching stuff this is not the
scientific study
in thailand this is the the teaching
style that we are
uh they're setting this is the turtle
module
so it's actually the the certain module
from brighton
that we use that we plugged inside a
thiodide
and then it produces animated svg
stuff so there is also documentation
it's in french so
sorry about that and you can get the
philosophy of the project
open source there is a kernel that is
plugged to
three front ends a console a notebook
and a jupiter
lab frontend this is
basically justicality that will be
presented later
by a generality
um about the notebook so we will have an
example
of how the personal channel can be run
in a classic notebook
so here is the pilot loading and this is
volume this is not
basically supported in directly i mean
in in paradise but it's a pure
python modules so we just need to
to patch it to to get nice rendering in
our
front end and here you will see
the famous small blonde from the french
alps
and all this works clean side
of course and i forgot to mention yeah i
forgot to mention that you have
um a compilation so i think i will come
back
to the the notebook just to to show you
that we have if we start volume
dots and we we eat tab then we have all
the completions that
here's an example this is purely fire
dive but just to
show you that this way i'm not in a web
worker that can
interact with the dom and and break the
the frontend actually
um we have also implemented um a request
module
it's basically um
ajax request so this seems to be a
python module but it's actually called
javascript from bioguide
then we we get some csv
file from this request and then we load
sound as
this statement so this is because
this way it's a bit long just to to show
you that the data frames
are nicely rendered in in our front
then uh coming back to the turtle module
we we managed to to teach our turtle how
to
hand drive so our turtle is able to
underwrite the stone so this is just a
p-style example
that we that we show
here um
actually the turtle module is really
appreciated by our teacher because
it's a nice way to teach
pro how to program another module that
is not present in pioneer is called
these
here it's a web assembly compilation
not by gasping but the web atomic
operation of the gravis
library that is the code from biodive
so as you can see you have a png svg
output
and it it runs nicely and this is not
part of skydive
we have also an intervention of p5.js
you write python code
and the python code
calls p5.js for you
with a setup and a draw function and you
can have nice 3d results like this
[Music]
there are also other p5 examples
yeah also oh this is fire simulation
it's a bit slow it's not really real
time it's a bit slow because during the
simulation i have the the
screen recording so this slow down my my
computer
but it's it's more more real-time if you
if you use it
in the gallery so you can test um
another p5 example just to show you that
it
also works out of the box in a in
a notebook so it's a particle simulation
so there is a setup and a draw function
with a particular class called bold and
that's managed interaction
i think we have another example here
this is a pure teaching module
this is not have to be implemented in
iodine
this is really for our purpose in
bathroom
um this is called computer this is not
our module but we integrate it in
bathroom
you just call the tutor function in the
cell
and it uh it produces this nice
rendering
of step by step execution at left and
that's right you have the
the the stack um visualization the
what's what's happening memory if you
have linked lists it can show it
if you have a dictionary etc um
yeah this is this is uh yeah just to
show you about python twitter
in python twitter actually you submit
your your code
uh the code is run on the web on a
server
so the iphone code is on on the server
and then you get that a bunch of data
that is used to
to produce this nice rendering this is
how patented
works and what we do is that we detect
the we took the
the code that's run on the server we run
it on biodive
to make it fully on size and we get this
bunch of data that's
used for the rendering from the browser
so it's
it's pretty computer fully on time
um that's it for the tool
um so there is other functionalities
that have not
presented in the video this is about um
you have you can
share some script and some notebook via
url so um if it's not too long then it
will work
uh it will compress your your script or
your notebook
and create a url uh that is not stored
it's not a tiny array you have
it's really uh putting the data in the
url
and it's an easy way to share small
notebooks in
small scripts in bathroom so you can see
you you can have more details about that
in the
in the documentation you can submit user
modules so
if you have dependencies on modules that
you
that you brought yourself then you can
put
it you can store it somewhere in the web
and you can give it in the param in the
url and
and then your it will work it will be
the dependencies will be load and it
will it will be importable
in faster
and you can have user's file that can be
submitted a csv
image is text if you if you want your
notebook to work on external data
then you put this the link to this data
on the url
um how it works so i will be maybe it's
it's not um
very technical this presentation is not
very technical but it can go differ in
the
states and technical details in the
questions
um but just to let you know that that's
from kernel actually use an event-based
app uh it's actually language and
front-end
it's just like this is quite close to
the jupiter messaging what
you have executed requests you have the
reply and
for for those who knows it's it's very
close
but it's not messaging it's even based
uh it's quite easy to plug to new front
end
to new languages we have implemented the
quite easily
new languages like sql javascript
okay ml and stuff
and if you if you fulfill
the api then it will work out of the box
in our two front ends even three front
end so
so it's quite easy to to to extend
and just to to say that the
the python part of the kernel um is
actually
by that module this means that we use
the the pi diffusion
for building our module it means
that are not standard libraries uh you
load the battery module and they
actually loads the camera so so our kml
is actually
written in python
so this is just a simple
schema that actually the first part was
already presented by roman
ransom um of the python plus some
modules
we we build our boston kernel
uh on top of that with javascript
and python stuff and our
bathroom console and that notebook just
reacts with this kml with some
javascript events
so we have plenty of limitations most of
them have been um
already mentioned by a woman
but we have some limitations that comes
from the fact that we are on the broader
so you can of course issues if you make
requests
you have i o i think and i think is
difficult it's trading is not supported
so so we are
of this we have all this stuff of course
limitation
we have some limitations from the
constitution's choices
we wanted it to be gdpr it does not mean
that
you don't have to sell good clients it
doesn't
mean that but to be gdpr we want it to
be fully on site
so it's hard to to to
to get code from the to a backup of the
code
uh on the server because it's purely
static
so this this uh limitations are mainly
bypassed by the capital project that
will be presented
in few minutes and um
there is also a limitation to start the
python ecosystem
even though the the piotr project
to my point of view is the one that is
the it's the better in in the
integration
of of the python ecosystem you have
several modules that
are really hard to to to integrate to to
so so um this is it will not be
as easy as uh p4 cooldown style of
course
so i think it's the end of my part so i
will
let nikola to to to present
the capital project that's built on top
of bastion
i just would like to thank um uh
the side attack community for for
hearing me
and and also the decided community that
that is here represented by romanco
so really thank you thank you to both
communities
okay thank you for this presentation
now i will introduce a use case of uh
iodide and particularly bestow in
an educational environment
let me share my screen
here we are
okay
so three years ago we initiated the
capital project
allowing teachers to create and share
python coding activities
with their class in high school
[Music]
the students can modify a copy
of the masterwork of the teacher and
then the teacher can review
and grade the work of his students all
data is saved in the cloud
the aim is to provide the working
environment on notebooks
without installing anything python or
having
to manually share ipmb files
the first version of capital was based
on
jupiter and a tool called
nba hosting a sort of binder created by
thierry parmentela from the french
institute
in riyadh but as the project grew
with an increasing number of users
the server began to experience
difficulties
and users were complaining about
slowness
this despite our efforts on
upgrading the hardware it was time
for padding shift so we we met
roman roma casatti six months ago
to try out an integration of bastogne
into capital
the hope we had was that bastogne could
handle a significant part of the server
load
delegating the python execution to the
browser instead
of our servers the bastown and capital
projects
have been adapted this way to that new
goal
on last december and january
five or six months ago today
we have a full integration of bastogne
into capital
and we count more than 25 000 users
in almost 800 schools running capital
and the majority of views
of uses involves the best from now
the feedback is very positive as with
bastogne the loading time has been
divided by
more than two uh from
15 seconds with the binder project
to less than six seconds with with
with a with basto moreover the load
on the servers has considerably
decreased
that made us able to offer the service
to the many school discrete that
requested it
all over the country this would
not have been possible for us with
our previous technology with
jupiter and embarrassing or binder
because of money a few limitations
however with bastogne as
roman said with modules because they're
not
all available but for what we need
for our youth in high school we already
have almost
everything and the list of supported
modules
grows very fast so so we're happy with
that
a conclusion after five months of use
of bastogne into our service capital
we can say that executing python in the
browser
is first effective because we can see
thousands of users every day
it's cheap and ecologic we don't
need anymore an expensive and energy
consuming
server and very scalable
that's the most important part we just
have to look at the bandwidth
uh to permit a kernel download uh freely
for
for every user um
it's okay i i finished my my
presentation
and if you have questions about capital
or bastogne
roman and i are available for
every question stop being share
of my screen thanks uh i think there
were quite a few questions actually
uh in the chat but
first of all i must say that a
over 26 000 users for a single jupiter
deployment
is quite an impressive number so kudos
for that
um and so there was a question by
roman yorshad but i think he's a host so
he can probably ask the question himself
yes i mean it was a more technical
question so
you say that uh you know when you encode
your notebook in the url
uh to share them is it i guess there is
a limitation on the size there that way
or
or is it big enough no there is a
limitation um
actually i can't answer what is the
limitation because the limitations
depend
on the browser so on the version of the
browser
and it also depends on the web server
so some web server will review the
request the url is too long
and some browser will refuse to to to
manage the request
if it's too long so so i can but i mean
um
it will work for i i managed to
to use it with the 2009 script
but for for a notebook actually it grows
quickly if if you take care of
of the output of your notebooks i mean
if you
if you delete all outputs just uh before
sharing
your notebook then you can have a quite
thick
notebook unless you have but by 64 uh
images uh that are in the in the
in the notebook so it could be quite big
but it depends on a lot of parameters so
so actually commenting on that uh
playing with this uh you know
encoding stuff in the url i think the
web standard only says that you should
support at least 2 000 characters which
is almost nothing but most browsers take
a few kilobytes
yeah um there was another question by uh
roman roma uh
which is about persistence like can
bastone process data remotely using
like a remote deep server or s3 buckets
um i i can't uh i don't understand the
um canvas data remotely you mean um
[Music]
you mean make a backup of the of the
data that are
uh um that are produced inside
the python code is that or
well i think you can answer the question
with your rest api
implementation maybe this is a like a
way to answer that
like like you actually store notebooks
on the server right
okay yeah but but it's um it's really
done in capital
it's not done in in in platform itself
but in capital
uh what's what we have is that you can
you can save a notebook you can
attach some files to the notebook so
it's a kind of
of cloud uh it's not it's
not this underneath not amazon f3
it's it's actually a drupal server
[Music]
the notebooks are stored in in databases
and the files are stored in
in the file system like like a classic
file and they are accessible via
the url but we take care of this and we
load the the external files
attached files we load them in the end
script and virtual file system
so this means that if you have attached
an image for example
to your activity then it will be
accessible
in the current directory in python so
this means if you want to do
peel loading of this image
and render it in the notebook then it
will work out of box
and and you will have to take care about
this url
and do the request but someone will
capitalize with the request for you
so i i i hope this this answer the
questions
i think it does there was a question
about whether it's possible to install
capital
outside of the capital uh
like essentially in other academies or
elsewhere
we provide the service for other
academies
already you we have to you have to to
contact
between academies uh i don't know though
the english word for for that is academy
do i have to contact them each other and
and then sign a paper to to share the
service
between between them it's uh it's all
already done
just to mention that if you want to try
best
on your own web server then on the the
western web page you can find
some some zip files
that you you you get them you put them
in your web browser
and it will work it's not capital but
you can try that
on your web server if you if you think
that our server will be
full then you can use it but it's not
full
nice uh so i don't think there are there
are any other questions
uh so let's move on actually uh so i'll
share my screen again real quick to
introduce our next speaker
next and last speaker uh so
our next speaker is jeremy tulu he is a
scientific software developer at quan
stack
and a core jupiter developer he's very
active in the jupiter lab
and voila projects and jeremy was
recently honored with the
jupiter distinguished contributors award
in 2021 and jeremy now is your turn
all right hello everyone so
let let's share the screen
okay so today i will do a quick demo
of a very very new project called
jupiter light and uh jupiter light is uh
what we call it was empowered jupiter
uh running in the browser and uh
to greet you all uh we're just going to
do
a little hello world right now so you
can find the
repo on github uh it's right here
and i think we are almost at 1000 stars
so if you want to
click the star button for free and reach
1000
maybe today so what you find on the remy
is like a couple of links to uh to
directly try it in your browser
so we're going to do uh just that so if
we click this
link we go directly to
website and that is actually uh read the
docs
so there is um a demo site that is
always
available for jupyter lite and that is
served by read the docs
and you can play around with it so this
one uh that i have here is also
uh on with the docs but it's using a
different uh front end that i find a
little bit better for like this kind of
presentation
uh it's using a new uh recently
announced front-end
um called a retro lab
there is actually a distribution of
jupiter lab
uh reusing the lab components uh lab
extensions and plugins
things like this so i'm going to uh
through through this notebook and show
you a couple of things
so now we're talking about browser-based
interactive computing
uh just like in boston but here we are
using
yeah once again the lab components so
yeah so we get the the thing we expect
from uh from a jupiter
uh frontend and uh we are using a kernel
called pyrolyte which is actually based
on pilodite which was presented earlier
so a little bit of history so this is uh
not that new uh in a way so jupiter
light is more like of a reboot
of many attempts of doing this these
kind of things
and one of the first was a project
called jive by
nick bolveg uh which was doing something
similar but with a slightly different
approach
more like a top-down approach trying to
patch a lab
instead of building it from uh from the
bottom up and
uh here we have a screenshot of uh jive
running a python kernel
and there there is also like a couple of
other kernels
javascript p5 and so on so this one
this was one of the uh of the first ones
uh
then we also had the p5 notebook uh that
was an attempt of doing
uh jupiter light but mostly focused on
the p5 so
we kind of find like this similar
components but um
very very very minimal interface so
at some point p5 notebook will uh will
be based on the jupiter light
but for now it's still its own thing we
have blast on that we are we
are we talked about earlier uh there is
also starboard that was mentioned
uh in the first presentation and there
is also observable
which is something a bit different than
the than jupiter so
it's more based on the reactive
programming and
it's also quite interesting but the
different paradigms
so with drip dry we get a
yeah python kernel a javascript corner
that runs in a knife frame
the notebooks that you interact with are
stored in the browser local storage
or in indexeddb if it's available
you can save your settings you can also
have multiple colors on the page
code consoles change your themes and
also basic support for
some of the visualization libraries so
we can just open the lab interface so we
can have
like more space to play with all of this
stuff so
here you get notebooks consoles
and a bunch of other things so on this
demo website we have
uh the tour extension that you can use
if you want to discover the
gplab interface it gives you like a
little tool or tells you what
what the ui does and things like this so
let's keep it
but you also find like other extensions
for example this one the jupyter app
draw io
so if you open it you can start
drawing diagrams and then save it and
you can close
and then you can open it again and you
find it again so
this is also another extension that we
just reuse as is so
there was no modification needed it just
works as a trip to app plugin
and yeah you can manipulate files so
here you have uh you can create a new
folder
uh you can for example remove this new
file here
and you go in the folder and then you
can also
open it from here um you can move it
back
up if you want so it really feels like a
real file system but
all of this goes to the local storage in
the end
so on the default website so if you
actually open the same url you will get
this uh examples
um folder uh i have a couple more here
but that was more for like the
playing around and also like trying
things on the on my browser
but if you go here um
let's see yeah let's open the javascript
one so
this one is very simple but just to show
that
uh javascript works in an iframe and you
do like
this kind of javascript things you can
also have markdown
magazine cells there is also a p5 so
this is not p5 in python but just p5.js
so you can execute all of this and then
there is a little magic to show the
sketch
i can tweak some values and then show
the sketch again
so let's do this
and then we have a little demo of
biolite
which is again based on a paradigm
that's just a little wrapper
it adds a couple of things um
and one of the things is a very simple
uh display module
that we can use here to show html marked
on
latex multiple clip figures
pandas data frames so here we define the
data frame in the cell
it takes a little while then we show it
again here so
let's wait for it
yeah and since it's triple derp you can
do a right click
and you can do a create new view for
output and you could keep it here if you
want
um another thing you can do so
yeah one thing to to notice is that uh
this kernel runs in uh in the webworker
uh and that is uh
uh intended but still we can do a
network request
using the fetch so here we fetch
uh some data from http bin
and uh we get the json response and the
cool thing with lab is we can use the
uh the json viewer so we can inspect the
request like this
if we want and use the all of the
different uh mime render extensions that
already exist in the enchanter lab
and finally simpli which is also
available by default in biodiet
can also be used here in the in the lab
interface
and it renders uh pretty nicely
so yeah my protlib we already looked at
renders there is a couple of others
other renderers from uh from the lab
so again those were just installed uh as
a
this new system of pre-built extensions
that was added in gp3
and uh and then loaded on the fly uh and
then you can get a
support for geojson so this is a bit
zoomed
yeah uh faster
but then you can also do uh something
else like if you want to open this
file it also shows you the json file
as a map there is also support for
for vega vega plots here and
recently we had an example with altair
so someone contributed a little snippet
here
to to get altered to work in uh in
jupiter light so
unfortunately one of the dependencies is
not a pure python wheel anymore so
so it's still a pinning to an older
version but once
we install this we can get some some
charts
we can install the data set
and we could can also have a interactive
visualization and i think one more
so i think you could pretty much just uh
let's see at the very top
yeah if you go to this uh website here
the gallery
i think copy pasting the examples might
just work once you have this
little bootstrap code here at the very
top so if you want to play around with
some uh some things you know out there
and get some
knife visualization uh it should be
quite uh quite convenient
to do and yeah so if you have a csv file
you can double click it it opens like
this as a csv
and yeah and from a couple of hours ago
i think
someone also contributed this example on
the on the repo so you need to
also do a bit of a micro pip magic in
the beginning
but once you have this you can import
volume and also show the the volume maps
and this one records also nothing
because
um jupiter can display them by default
so yeah that was um
that was a little tour so yeah again you
can also open
png files like this if you want and uh
yeah so let's go back to this notebook
here
yeah talking about use cases i think
they are quite similar to
uh to the one that uh uh bastogne
uh also covers so you have a lightweight
uh
frontend running in the browser there is
no need for a server
well static service serving static files
is pretty much it and no command line uh
no dependency management all of the
tedious things
and also boots pretty quickly i put
pretty much in seconds so the one we
were using is on read the docs but there
is also
so if you open this repo here
it's a very small demo and
it has just a couple of files and all of
the
logic is pretty much in the github
action here that fetches
a new uh the release of the light and
then
extracts it and then just use
an action to credit to github pages so
if you go back here
and you click here then you get your
jupyter lite
website uh deployed automatically on
github every time you commit to the main
main branch so yeah
then yeah education was also of course
covered by
uh bastogne and the capital project but
i wanted to
just show this uh quick video that paige
bailey posted on twitter a couple of
days ago
uh that is kind of a mock-up using uh
jupiter light uh of what github
could look like if uh if we had
uh interactive notebooks uh directly
like on github so it could be really
nice to have this kind of
feature at some point on github because
you could just point
uh students to a repo and they could
just start playing around with it
without doing
anything at all not even opening a new
tab because it would just be
right there when they arrive so yeah
that's quite cool
i don't think there is any encode for
this it was pretty much just
a mock-up but still quite nice to see
these kind of ideas around
yeah so this is not yet a reality but at
some point
uh it should be possible to build your
own uh psych frontend so for now you
have
let's see yeah so this demo site is a
jupiter light plus a couple of
extensions but
ideally there could be an exporter so
that you could specify a lot of
different things like extension settings
uh content and and more and then you
could just click a button and then you
get this zip file that you could deploy
uh somewhere else so this was a markup
by uh nick baldwick
and i think it would be really great to
to have at some point uh yeah to just
make it easy
easier to for anyone to just customize
their own
light deployment uh another idea of
jupiterite is that we can
start reusing some of the main
components like the typescript
components
uh in other projects uh for example
voila the quads front-end
and other lab-based applications
and when it comes to deployment so we
already covered
uh github pages and with the docs but it
should also work
uh pretty easily on on git lab pages uh
also on binder uh actually
jupyterlight also has a binder
deployment as
using the jupiter server proxy if you
want and we also had a virtual
deployment at some point
so all of this will be documented here
soon but if you also want to contribute
on the commission for this um
on another platform uh free so yeah for
example netflix
notify nginx and the heroku
so yeah anything that can serve uh
static files pretty much
works so yeah a quick
note on let's see this uh
yeah on the
on the way this thing works so
um jupy light is pretty much uh
like just a set of plugins so everything
is a plugin uh so jupyter lab itself is
already
a lot of like 70 plugins by default
also we have this new lab distribution
code
retro lab which is also a jupyter
distribution we're using a lot of
plugins from lab
but also having its own plugins so
all of this goes in the uh this thing we
call the front end
so yeah what runs in your web browser
but
um there is also a jupiter light uh
part that also runs in the browser um
there is also based on
this plug-in architecture which is
exactly the same as the one that lab
uses
so lab uses this lumino
plugin system and there is this
similar system on the on the jupyter
light so here you see that
for example the contents module
the sessions the kernels all of these
are plugins and that means that
if someone wants to use something else
for the contents they don't want to
store it in local storage they could for
example
swap it for something else so uh
swapping plugins is very common in uh in
jupyter lab
so very often people provide like
different plugins for like the file
browser or things like this
uh so here they could provide something
else for the contents manager for
example that stores files on
on s3 or remote server
and using this plugin system we can also
support more kernels
so we have by default three colors it's
just they are just in the same repo for
now just to make it easy but
at some point it might be uh move to
other ripples
uh maybe there will be only one kernel
supported by default uh let's see
so yeah um python kernels javascript
control pretty much anything that could
run
in a browser so this is one of the the
thing like
uh one of the goals of jupiter light is
also to be very
uh agnostic just like a project jupiter
in general
and like uh roma i mentioned earlier the
best one also
works uh in jupiter light uh so that's
uh that's quite nice
uh so it kind of validates all of the uh
uh approach on both uh jupiter light and
also on baston so that's
pretty really good to see this uh these
components working together
so yeah um gp light is pretty much based
on uh
components like we already discussed and
yeah if you play around with the demo
you might see some
some little auditors but that's normal
because we are using the very very very
latest
uh packages so currently at alpha 11
that was released yesterday so at least
we get all of the cool stuff
and the new features but there might be
some some issues still
so yeah
one of the cool features coming in trip
to lab 3.1 is real-time collaboration
and there is a pull request open here uh
on the chapter right to also enable this
in this uh application here
and um yeah so if you look at this uh
this gif
uh you see that actually on the left you
have a triple lab open
and on the right you have a retro lab
and both can actually um
talk to each other so they you can
collaborate on the same document
using two different interfaces on
jupiter light so you don't need to do
anything else but just go to
a url and i was wondering maybe let's
see i don't know how much time we have
here maybe
what we could do is uh let's see if i do
this
and paste this link here in the chat
i don't know if you get it but maybe we
will see i think
soon enough right so if you open the
readme and then you go
yeah so if you follow the link and you
open the remi
maybe maybe we will see each other so
so yeah still a couple of issues i see a
new cursor here
so i think the document yeah the
document might be reloading every time
someone joins but yeah
nice to see some people
cool i mean that's also the risk of like
demos right but i mean
it's also fun so yeah
okay so um
[Music]
yeah so what's up next um
we are currently focusing on the i want
to see a screenshot of that again
i want to tweet that okay sure
please i mean we can also go
to uh maybe a notebook if you want so
yeah it's even better
yeah actually some people could stay in
the redmi file
and while others opened so you have to
open the notebook with the same name
because this is how the room is kind of
created so this is how users are
grouped together but here you might see
a little um
issue with new cells created but i think
it should work otherwise
yeah let me know when you're done with
your screenshots
it's done okay yeah
okay so if someone feels uh adventurous
you can open the biolite uh
notebook in the examples repo uh
folder but otherwise it's uh it's fine
we can move on
yeah ah yeah there is someone here
yeah this is a test but you can actually
do a
printing here
execute and then i think the the
outputs will also be synchronized uh
with
everybody so all of this is really uh
yeah i want to insist on this it's
really just reusing
a lot of the work that was put in
jupiter lab and that was
uh put by uh kevin eric
carlos and everybody who worked on rtc
before so that's a
it's really great that we can just uh
reuse that
almost almost for free so yeah probably
going to close this
it seems to be a little bit glitchy at
the moment but
uh yeah so yeah many thanks to everybody
uh
who can who could make uh this possible
yeah so mvp project so the goal is to
have something that
kind of is you know the first version um
there are still a couple of things to
improve the tooling uh people should be
able to
write uh several light extensions so
that means
something that extends the server part
of trypto light that still runs in the
browser but still
and uh some ids are new kernels
uh for example one that is powered by a
webassembly which is a sql.js
uh maybe another one powered by uh
excuse python if we manage to compile
uh access python to web assembly at some
point uh maybe alternative content
manager like we already talked about
authentication and uh
even remote kernels uh running somewhere
else should be possible like if you have
one
running on a binder a little bit like
the
um thieb lab project does so that should
also
be possible it could be very fun to see
a lot of tools
to go into the deployment direction so
everything that could make uh deployment
easier especially when it comes to
reusing
uh chip lab extensions and also sharing
content and data easily
so for now you have to do the copying by
hand but yeah
it's very new we haven't got like the
tooling in place yet but uh
normally it should be it should be
possible to do this and of course
uh i think a lot of that will just reuse
what is currently done in jupiter libra
already so
so yeah um jupiter widgets also
coming at some point hopefully uh
properly
is almost there so it displays but uh i
think there are some issues with ipython
so
maybe something to look into at some
point maybe it's something that could
also share
be shared between boston and and write
is like a common ipython
uh that will run in the browser uh that
would be great to have
so yeah uh many thanks uh for listening
uh playing with the demo uh to nick
balbach who contributed
a lot uh to the repo and everybody else
who
also contributed in uh many different
ways
so yeah thank you
wow i was literally blown away by the
real-time collaboration
the fact that it was possible to enable
it right away
so there was a question by olivier but i
can
let him respond actually ask a question
himself
the the the question was do you use a
crdt
complete conflict-free replicated data
types
as the data structure to enable
collaborative editing like from a
theoretical point of view
yeah so it's uh completely based on a
library called yjs that
is offered by kevin chance that we work
with
and i think if you go to the
uh lab repo
you might see some more information so
yeah if you go
here maybe search for shared editing
um yeah
so yeah just yeah
so it was it's based on the on the
jupiter lab the
default component and it's actually
enabled by jupiter light
without changing anything yeah
so what one thing that changed uh
is and it's very very minimal and thanks
again
to the plug-in system is uh jupiter
light uses
a different provider so sorry for all
the code but
instead of using the default websocket
provider that is in lab
and there is also talking to endpoint
that is a part
of lab uh drip drive is using a webrtc
provider
so in the end you will end up with the
plugin that looks like this so maybe it
would be better to show it
on a different yeah
like right here so if you yeah
this is pretty much real-time
collaboration
in jupiter light yeah that's very
impressive
yeah thank you very much quite nice yeah
very nice demo and a very nice
presentation thank you very much
so i don't see any other questions and
uh
so i think this is it i'm going to
actually stop the recording
just just maybe one question yeah
so so do you have any like difficulties
from the fact that you're running in the
web worker
like uh do you have to like serialize
objects back and forth
how does it uh what's your experience
with it yeah
so the kernel uh speaks almost all of
the
the triple protocol so yeah messages
they go
you know they flow as json json blobs
but the main difficulties i think are is
you know for example macbook leave at
the moment uh requires a little patch
because we can't use the default backend
that is available in paradight
but there are like some ids to make it
work in the web broker
but um yeah i think the main reason for
having it in a web broker was to
you know open lab here and have uh
actually multiple colors like i forgot
to show that but here if you go here
like
um just like in japan you could open
a previous corner if you want so here
and still
in memory uh so here normally if you
execute it again
yeah execution count is changing so you
kind of pick up where you left
and uh having it in a web worker felt
like the most natural
but of course uh using the the plug-in
system
it's definitely possible uh to just have
uh
something that is not in the web worker
and i think that was the that is how the
best on
integration is uh currently working with
uh with jupiter light yeah
thank you great great work by the way
the
jupiter light reached 1000 stars
nice thanks sir sorry and
uh so the number 1000 is is roma roman
questi
and so yeah which is pretty cool
congrats congrats on this okay